avec son clocher fraîchement rénové
l'église semble plutôt bien conservé
mais une fois à l'intérieur c'est une
toute autre réalité nous avons ici une
abside du 11e siècle dans laquelle il y
a des fresques qui mérite d'être
entièrement restaurée et de façon assez
rapide mais la liste des dégâts ne
s'arrête pas là dit trop cassé ou encore
murs fissurés au total six cent mille
euros de travaux sont à prévoir alors
forcément l'aide financière du loto du
patrimoine sera la bienvenue
ça nous donne tout de suite une belle
planification pour nos travaux ça va
nous permettre de les faire certainement
beaucoup plus rapidement que ce qu'on
avait prévu est de préserver ce très
beau bois très moines dès que possible
un soutien pour un lieu d'exception 1200
m² de fresques réalisées avec du
silicate de potasse une technique
utilisée à l'époque par mesure
d'économie mais qui sur le long terme
fait tout son effet et jean qui restaure
n'est pas un tueur actuellement qui ont
découvert cette technique là nous disent
que ça apportait une certaine
vitrification à à la peinture et les
peintures sont finalement
pas très très dégradés
sont bien résisté au temps c'est sur
tous les supports derrière qui qui sont
dégradées et qui risquent les alter eu
pour sauver ce patrimoine les tickets du
loto sont en vente à 15 euros l'unité
dès aujourd'hui jusqu'au tirage prévu le
16 septembre